news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so you really have to see this to
believe it a long time viewer ned
sent me this clip and it is unbelievable
rudy giuliani
went on fox business yesterday to again
tell his wild conspiracies about how
hunter biden
flew from california 3 000 miles to the
east coast to drop off three laptops at
a repair shop run by a legally blind guy
and got off the plane drunk and drove to
the repair shop and then never picked up
the laptop
so the repair guy looked at his private
emails and then sent them to the fbi
that completely ridiculous story rudy
was on fox business to talk about
and it's all so ridiculous that even the
fox interviewer
who goes by the name kennedy actually
had to push back a little bit because
what rudy was saying is so absurd
and when she brings up rudy giuliani
acting sort of like christopher steele
of the steele dossier
rudy loses it starts demanding an
apology
you have to see this we're gonna jump in
several minutes in
rudy's been ranting for about three four
minutes completely incoherently
and kennedy starts to sort of question
are these laptops even really hunters
is this stuff really hunters and it
starts to get a little bit ugly take a
look
hunter biden allegedly dropped the
laptop off in april 2019.
i i i believe that completely um
but you only came in possession of this
ten days ago
so they've just been floating around for
a year and a half so how do we know
that these laptops if if you have
cracked the encryption how do we know
that other people haven't
and placed some of this stuff on here
especially the most salacious stuff
when will you show the evidence to prove
that these are unadulterated
devices i gave it i gave it all to the
new york post and they've done their own
separate verification of it with
independent experts
and they came to the conclusion that
it's his hard drive
there are internal uh pieces of
information here
that only he could have that i know from
my investigation
okay so kennedy starting to ask
reasonable questions
and then keeps getting more and more on
rudy's nerves
and kennedy then says you know we're
gonna have to look into this ourselves
because
it's sort of sounding a little bit weird
rudy and then kennedy says
you're sort of playing the role of like
a christopher steele
rudy flips and demands an apology take a
look at this
you see 50 pictures all right come on
here's what we'll do we will have uh
the people in our news departments
verify
all of this because um it sounds
like there may be something here that is
fishy that is causing
americans it's giving the pause and
other stuff
that might have been completely
adulterated over the 18 months
and some could say that you were acting
like christopher steele
that that you were abstracting
information and
because you've got to be kidding me i
was acting i was acting like christopher
steele that's what it sounds like when
you
apologize you better apologize for that
i mean i've been i've been a united
states attorney associate attorney
general
mayor of new york city and a member of
the bar for 50 years
i've never been accused of anything and
you're accusing me of being christopher
steele
i'm accusing you of that's outrageous
so that escalated very quickly it goes
from rudy having
essentially seven minutes to rant
incoherently
to rudy demanding an apology from the
interviewer and accusing her of
defamation
you have to love it let's keep going and
rudy just keeps demanding apologies
of me of my reputation
every single thing is here and i want
you to look at it
and then you apologize to me
well you can you can you can come to my
office and you can look at it and
tomorrow night you can apologize to me
for saying i'm like christopher steele i
told you there are underage girls there
there are i told you there are documents
that show
that he's getting 10 there are there are
documents that show that he's getting
half
of what hunter gets there are and when
they're there i want you to apologize to
me okay because you just defend me
absolutely and that's outrageous because
you have no basis for that
i came on your show in good faith to
give you evidence
that is being withheld from the american
people and i get defamed
isn't that great rudy wants to be able
to peddle these obvious lies and these
ridiculous
disjointed conspiracy theories with no
resistance
any resistance even mild and meek
is not going to be allowed and kennedy's
doing her best not to allow
rudy to rant endlessly with no with no
questions being asked
then rudy decides we've got to end this
interview
that's outrageous all right are you
still working on behalf of the president
i think our interview
i think our interview is now over i
haven't even gotten i don't talk to
people
or the part about 1994 in the video
music awards
that was the last time you and i were on
camera and it's taken
this long and and these yeah and
beautiful this may be the last time
we'll be on camera
because i don't let people call me
christopher steele i'm sorry
christopher seal is a criminal you're
asserting that i'm a criminal
eastern europe is a cesspool and
i didn't get them from eastern europe i
didn't get them from eastern europe you
are now
repeating lying propaganda from the
democratic national committee
and the crooked biden family i had
nothing to do with eastern europe
i got this from the the repair man who
corroborates it
yeah come on kennedy that's not fair he
didn't get the stuff from eastern europe
he got it from a legally blind guy who
didn't actually say he identified
hunter biden as the guy dropping off the
laptops but he saw a bo
biden sticker on the laptops and
determined
that clearly was hunter biden who
dropped these laptops off to me
three thousand miles away from where he
lives you're not being fair to rudy by
allowing him to tell that story
what a world what a world we live in and
then here are just the last few moments
rudy attacking the interviewer as not
being informed
all right do you regret i have this is
this is hunter biden's
this is hunter biden's material it is
proven a hundred times over and i have a
voice recording of him
in which he talks about being in
business with a chinese spy master maybe
you should play the recording
and see if i don't have it it's been all
over the internet today
and if you were better informed you
would have known that oh i've
i've read plenty about this i have and
it's it's
have you heard the recording that's been
out there all day of hunter biden
saying that he is in business
with the chinese spy master patrick ho
and that his big partner the richest man
in china
may be dead and that he and his father
may be called as witnesses
did you hear that one no we haven't we
have not been able to
verify large swaths of the material
that has allegedly come because that's
because you don't want to verify it i
would love to hear your your
your uh your sister your sister
your sister your sister and entity the
new york post has verified it
it took five days to do it i have
you think they're printing false
material you think rupert murdoch would
let them print false material
heavens now just because i gave it to
them and there's the sort of
catch to this entire thing it's not
about
let them print knowingly false material
it's about printing unverified
speculative material and the answer is
of course that's what the new york post
does and then
fox news opinion people use it to say
hey this was reported by the new york
post giving them sort of
a veneer of uh plausible deniability
it's just hilarious
and really this is no big praise of
kennedy this is just
again it's like the people who are
criticizing leslie stahl for being
you know too tough on trump in any other
country with a free press i mean okay
north korea you're not going to get it
but in other countries
with the free press presidents are much
more regularly exposed to tough
questioning
and any mild questioning rudy just
doesn't want
and uh rudy just just think as we have
six days now left until this election
rudy is on that list along with jared
kushner
and ivanka kaylee maganny don jr
that is the list of people who hopefully
after tuesday we never have to hear from
again
that is as much as i'm incentivized to
remove trump
because we need somebody to start riding
the ship i am also very incentivized by
getting
all of these clowns off at until they
get deals to be
contributors to fox news of course at
least temporarily off of the airwaves
as people involved in government really
really insane stuff
but at least to the extent that kennedy
caused rudy to implode
nicely done nicely done but don't go too
far praising her
uh because she is still you know who she
is